マウントなんとですねなんと一人で
お店に行きましたあれですよあの一人で来るまでですよ
あのお母さんの車をマミーの車を借りているなぁちょっと悩ましいの方に
茶房れって言うという橋の舌のショッピングセンターに来てるんですけど
まあで僕の抜きはドライビング技術をねいいですね見せようと思います
まずは右左右を確認してすっかり今ねチェックしてずっと何すっっ
ねまあねこういうテーマね結局ね
どう言えばいいのかなっていうねま受験に高域も行ってみまーねっ
蘭友会ね僕も一応ベンチャー強い一体してますから
うっ点というのは結局ねこういう自分との戦いと言いますか
安全を確認して危険を予測するはそういうところはすべて勝ってね
結局小指ツアーだきてるよねまあ金っていう優先すればいいんですよ
しかし攻めるとバー攻めるとなるとか止まるはしっかりねこうねまぁ
こういうね結局金前田車についていけばね
なんとかなるって言うところがいつあげてるねっ
もうねまあこういう感じで打ってんっていうね
やはり個々の能力のねらーメイクを示されるてね
止まれとばしっかり止まる
で確認してからちょっとずつ前に進んで秋田屋来週じゃないまあねっ
本当はね音楽を聞きたいんだけどね著作権的な音があるからね
今だ
スムーズに進む線 ok i 軽いん
4話ドライブ4位をはじめよ
な左方向
ねまあねこうやってねっ彼は神がですはいあしかしね
ちんの足場に留まるってね安心ぐのぐでここ行っていいかわからない
ポイント a子自信がないよこれ犯罪かなあー
戦後ないなぁいいんですよ
しっかり止まるとかあってもらっている
実直だね
まあ運転が楽しいものなんですライブ後ろでくる免れそう
おりスピードが遅いからさ
上がっていったつなぐ道何か ok 雨名となく泣くな泣くな
どの a これくんなよ
くんなよするぞまたす others
すっぱ猫入れないこういった試合の気持ちがて bounty まで必要不可欠ですね
基本的に人間はね助け合って生きる生き物ですから
こういうことをねしっかり心に刻んでないまーうんていテーマのドライビング
ちょリビングと英語といいんですけどまあそうよね失敗えっ
で綾部まっすぐ行っちゃったやべやべやべ
イヤーで終わった fn 枯れてくれるこれ今抜かれて別れた
じゃ
ん
まぁ結局はねまあねっ
ママのん
マウントをなんとですね
あここでね左に曲がるっていうね高等技術をね皆さんに見せようと思ったんですけど
みんなシーンのもので
こともできます
左に行きたいところなんですけれどもまあね
信号が上がって来たよ
まぁ今日はこの辺にしておきましょう c
b
ん